hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the issues
that inevitably arises for any
religiously oriented philosopher is the
relationship between some sort of faith
whether we understand that in terms of
lived faith or an experience or
adherence to certain scriptures or
doctrines and the Faculty of human
reason and often these are viewed as
opposed to each other or there's a neat
dividing line between them for st.
Augustine in on free choice of the will
it's not going to be quite so
antagonistic a relationship and in fact
what we're going to see is the the way
in which he conceptualizes it along with
his student who is following along with
them of odious is that the - you might
say reinforce each other and and help
each other out so there isn't this very
common presumption of something either
being of faith or of reason and these
being two wholly separate modes that
might be you know super ordinated in
some way so that faith is over reason or
reason is over faith instead they they
they cooperate with each other
in ways that we'll see here so to begin
with early on in the work already in
Chapter four
Augustine says when his student is
asking him about a very difficult
question about evil Augustine says
you're inquiring into a problem which
deeply interested me when I was quite a
young man it troubled me so much I was
worn out and driven right into heresy
you can find that in his confessions
solo did I fall etc etc if God had not
helped me because I longed to find the
truth I could not have escaped or
recovered the primary freedom to search
so what he's saying there is that God in
some way aids the human Enquirer in
seeking out the truth the theme that
we'll come back to momentarily what he
goes on then and he says I will explain
it it's you and the way I finally worked
out God will help us and make us here's
the key idea understand what we believe
so two important terms there belief or
believe in credit a in Latin and you
know sometimes it's used in in other
ways
credo means I believe when we talk about
having a Creed it's coming from that and
then understanding in tell it again a
right to be able to literally apply our
intellect to it and make sense of it now
a lot of people would say well these are
two different you know modes of
apprehension one of them is deficient in
relation to the other you might think
about Plato for example talking about
you know grasping something with
knowledge with a piston a or through
noose or do noia
and then having mere opinion Doakes ah
right having it could be write opinion
but it's merely believing something not
actually knowing it an Augustine brings
up this this passage that he uses quite
frequently coming from the book of
Isaiah the Septuagint version
Augustine gives priority to the Greek
versions of the text rather than the
Hebrew versions of the text and the
Greek Septuagint there in fact is a
passage that translated into Latin goes
nisi credit or ETS known and 10 agates
meaning unless you believe you will not
understand and so the idea here is you
have to have some sort of starting point
for the inquiry you have to believe in
something that doesn't mean that you
dogmatically or unquestioningly or
blindly believe in it because the very
fact of putting it out there is
something that you believe then
inevitably leads to trying to go beyond
the mere belief and to understand but
unless you do in fact have some sort of
commitment according to Augustine at
least a temporary commitment of belief
you're not going to arrive at
understanding if you dictate that
understanding has to come first and only
after that we can believe you'll never
according to him get the process started
so he says we can be sure that we're
treading in the paths pointed out by the
prophet Isaiah right we believe and then
he says what is it we actually believe
everything which create is which exists
is created by one God that God is not
the cause of sin so then how do we trace
back this this you know causality so
that God is not responsible for sin
notice that belief here is not what it
is for many people in the past and in
the present a way of closing a question
a way of blocking the path to inquiry
and study says Wow
believing in some things really raises
some problems for us that then we are
called to go beyond the mere belief and
figure out this is what makes it
Christian philosophy and not just say
believing in Christianity and then then
proceeding on there's an attempt to try
to provide an intelligibility to it to
understand and I think another really
key aspect of this that you see coming
up over and over again in this work and
in other Augustinian works you
is this notion that God will assist God
will help out in some way God will
contribute not by like giving you the
the answer automatically or just popping
it into your head but in some way by by
lending some strength or you know
guiding slightly here and there or
giving some confidence that's needed in
order to make some progress so God
assists The Enquirer or in this case two
inquires Augustine and his student who
desires the truth so that's another key
element of it it's not that God is just
gonna help anybody whatsoever sort of
like you know throwing out answers here
and there right instead God will help
the Inquirer who actually wants to
understand that presumes that there is
in fact a desire for the truth that is
something more than say a desire for
notoriety or a being seen as a big shot
or a desire to control people or a
desire to make money off of you know
your teaching any of those other things
desire for truth would be something that
that would be higher and better than
those and would fit in with with some of
the other things that Austin is soon
going to discuss a little bit later he
says that using reason relying on our
Faculty of reason this is in section 14
with God's help difficulties can be
worked out so he says whatever
difficulties may threaten us they are
cleared away and all become smooth with
God's help this doesn't mean again that
God just comes in and says here's the
answer's no the puman being has to use
the Faculty of reason has to you work
towards understanding so he says raising
our thoughts to him seeking his help let
us examine the problem before us and
that is exactly what Augustine does over
and over and over again in this work
with his student examines the problem
before them and starts digging into it
hoping that that something is going to
come out of this and having some
confidence in that so you know we might
think about well what kind of matters
are actually getting clarified in this
this work a little bit later too I
should mention and this is in section 17
he says see how easily a task is
accomplished with God's help which
people think very difficult I confess I
had thought this problem which I find we
have solved might hold us back for as
long as we'd already taken over the
discussion so there is this this you
know sort of celebrating the fact that
they're able to get somewhere so what
are they able to get somewhere with well
one thing that they talk about is the
distinction between human beings and
animals and that bears partly upon our
Faculty of reason or intellect or spirit
movies says you could call it whatever
you want the human mind higher than the
merely animal which does a lot of cool
things but is not a human being it's not
rational and it doesn't understand
things conceptually like we do so this
is an important distinction that gets
worked out and and that's the point
where the student actually says early on
well I believe that but I don't fully
understand it so Augustine then says all
right let's let's understand it let's
apply our Faculty of reason so that we
can understand how rationality makes
human beings different another key issue
that they're preoccupied with the entire
first book is what is the nature of
wrongdoing
what makes doing things wrong actually
wrong and you notice that the student of
odious will bring up several different
possibilities at different points and
Augustine is leading him along they're
engaged in a process of rational inquiry
and at times the student will actually
say well I mean this is what the law
says an Augustine says you're appealing
to Authority they're not bad but not
exactly what we want to be doing instead
we want to be thinking things
out right so from a basis of belief they
again move into understanding eternal
and temporal law this is another key
thing which gets introduced and worked
out in considerable detail in this first
book of free choice of the will the
eternal law is the divine law God's law
that that sort of you know is behind the
scenes than temporal or human law are
the particular laws made in particular
communities governing those people and
it can be you know sometimes in
accordance with the eternal law
sometimes not but the eternal law is
what we should be using according to
Augustine for our moral choices and
judgments and evaluations and again how
do we understand the eternal law we we
don't just believe that it's there we
try to understand it another key thing
that's being clarified here and it's on
free choice of the will is the scope of
the will what is the will what does it
do as it turns out the will is in fact
involved in wrongdoing when it chooses
something other than following the
eternal law or choosing you know
temporal goods over higher goods or when
it chooses to abandon the Justice it has
in its own will all of these things are
being worked out within this framework
of you know which can be understood in
terms of unless you believe you will not
understand first belief comes and belief
is not the end of the matter
it's not a unshakable foundation as you
know will come about in later
foundationalism no it's a starting point
that provides some initial
intelligibility and then the question is
as human beings endowed with a Faculty
of reason how much more intelligibility
can we provide to these matters provided
we seek truth and ask for divine help so
that's Augustine's view in a nutshell on
the relations between Christian faith
and human reason
in this this particular work
you